hi everyone my name is tyler oakley and
i am here today to tell you all about my
firsts
[Music]
first person you came out to oh i think
the first person i came out to i'm not
going to name her because she was
terrible and she outed me to other
people but you know what you did you
know who you are
will you bleep her name
god bless first youtube video of yours
that you'd want to scrub from the
internet uh well my very first video is
privated because i did not know about
privacy and in my first video i talked
all about like here's my address here's
where you can find me here's my phone
number all these things and i'm like the
internet doesn't need to know about that
so probably my very first video first
time you were recognized in public i
so i started making youtube videos when
i was still in the dorms when i was
going to michigan state and i remember
there was a like a squad of little girl
not little girls like college students
girls going through my hallway and they
like came by my room when my door was
open and i'm like just hanging out my
dorm room and there i can hear them
coming and like giggling and something
and then they all peeked in and then
from that point on i knew
i had to keep my door closed first date
which well like with a guy or with a
girl with a girl um i think we went like
ice skating she came out as a lesbian by
now i came out as a gay by now jules god
bless ya look at us now queer out proud
a first date with a guy it was like a
secret because
people couldn't know we went to go see
um stepford wives i think
in theaters and when he dropped me back
off at home my parents i didn't want my
parents to know so he dropped me off
down the street and then i like scurried
home and i got home and we only had our
one computer with our dial up and so i
was like waiting to get online to talk
to all my friends and tell them oh my
god i just got home from the day and we
kissed blah blah blah but i had to wait
because we had dial up and my brother
was on the phone and so there i was just
like
i need to tell the gays about what i'm
up to times have not changed first gay
pride i came to la
in 2010 for a summer internship with the
trevor project and while i was here for
the summer i really just was feeling my
gay oats it was like the first time i
saw gays out in public doing their thing
and so the first gay pride i went to was
la pride and i feel like i like dove
right into the deep end and
i had fun
first job my first job was at arby's and
i hated it i but i will say whoo girl to
this day there is nothing as good as a
curly fry my first job that i loved was
mcdonald's and all my friends worked
there we all have the same shift every
day it was great i had so much free food
that's all that's my barometer for a
good job i worked at a coffee shop all i
did at the coffee shop was chug
frappuccinos all day long at arby's all
i did was chug jamoka shakes all day
long anywhere where i got free food that
was a good job so youtube is not it's
not all it's cracked up to be no free
food first impression of your amazing
race partner cory cool
so corey and i met back in the dorms he
was an r.a and i was freshman and i saw
his picture on like the board
of like all the ras in the building and
i could tell because you know how gays
know i was like
that's a gay as a gay does i did my
stalking i found him on facebook and
then i saw in his interests he liked big
brother and julie chen and so i reached
out and i said hi i too like big brother
and julie chen we should like
hang out sometime
the rest is history thank you julie chen
first incorrect rumor you've read about
yourself everything i've ever read is
true
everything there was a moment i do
remember there was a moment where there
was a conspiracy that youtubers that
were gay were doing it as like a lie
and i got dragged into that and i was i
wanted to be like honey not only have i
not had never had like a big big reveal
of like i'm gay and like getting it
doing it for views or anything like that
like i've always done i've always liked
talked about being gay so like that was
flabbergasting to me i'm like
i don't have the energy first kiss
it was in a
van uh it was it was after my first date
with a boy and but like that's like
first real kiss like i think spin the
bottle doesn't count though i was always
very like yeah we should play spin the
bottle of course it was a good kiss
we're still friends first youtube video
first youtube video that i ever made it
was called an introduction to my video
blog seo ready it was like it was me
just showing people around my dorm room
in college and i showed people like
here's my bunk bed here's my condoms
that my ra gave me here's my whatever
i'm like as if anybody cared here's my
hebrew book for hebrew class like nobody
cared
no
i don't go back and watch this week's
video like as soon as i'm done filming
it like i don't want to see it i don't
want to think about it it is bizarre
though because i've made a video every
week
for almost 11 years now almost 12 years
now and to be able to go back and see
what i cared about
any week in the past more than a decade
is nobody needs that type of access to
your brain first car now this is a good
story i saved up all of my arby's money
and i knew that i needed a vehicle so i
went in the newspaper people don't even
do this anymore oh my god i'm like aging
myself i went in the newspaper i circled
the ones that i was interested in i
was going to go check out this car
with my dad and the night before i got
into high school shenanigans so i was
not feeling my best the next morning the
morning i was supposed to check out the
car and i'm like in the car with my dad
on my way to go check out the car that i
circled and i'm like oh she's feeling
queasy she's feeling like i'm like not
this is
it's all gonna come up last night's
gonna
regurgitate and so we get to the the
house and
i
go around the back to the side of the
house
and i'm like dad i have to go puke i am
so hungover i go and puke and i look up
after i just like vomited all of last
night and i see the woman who was
selling the car through her window we
make eye contact and i was like
yup this is this is what my life is
and then she came out of the house and i
said hello
and we had a moment and i ended up
buying her car her car was a something
oldsmobile where it was completely blue
with one red door it was all i could
afford with my arby's money first
youtuber friend corey my amazing race
partner we met the day i made my youtube
account and we both made youtube
accounts and we would like make our own
little collabs and do our own little
challenges and this is before like
before vidcon existed before
anything
and um
he's still my first youtube friend
first celebrity crush
chris o'donnell
in batman and robin
as robin
the close-up zoom
of his first reveal of his outfit where
they like showed his pecs and like
somehow his metal armor had nipples
protruding and little me in the basement
of my home would rewind it but watch it
on the like the lowest volume possible
and i would rewind it and watch and
rewind it and watch and rewind it and
watch it i was like oh just say he's
a man if y'all had him behind a door i
would i would have to leave
because of the restraining order
[Music]
you